we'll get started
good morning my
the Senior Director for foundational
technologies in IT s I am also a
co-sponsor with our chief information
security officer on what we call the
next generation network which is his
sessions about what I was going through
the website this morning and I was
looking at this and I was like wow
strengthen your own network what does
that mean and for me it means the
foundation strengthening the foundation
of our network across campus is
important to me so I was great that to
see this theme for this conference so
next generation network ultimately what
it does is it provides a more Mardin
resilient secure network across campus
but it has a much bigger reach even
outside of campus you know the network
itself is you know it's very old and
we're seeing today more and more demands
on that network to help advance the
research especially research the
clinical care and the academic areas I
was at a conference a few weeks ago
called the common solutions group was
about 20 universities that attended
nationwide out of all the places it was
in Nebraska so I went to the University
of Nebraska for this conference and the
topic one of the topics there was
talking about campus networks there was
about 10 universities that were doing
very similar to what we're doing what
you're going to see about how we're
going to modernize our network different
stages different areas but the question
was really what's driving that change
security is is is huge for us and and I
don't I don't mean cyber security from
external attacks that's there we have
defenses for that but it's internally as
well it's when people bring their own
devices they get on the network there's
things that are happening there's a lot
of what we call east-west traffic within
the network that we don't know sometimes
what's happening or
even hard to find where it is increased
devices IOT devices bring your own
devices AV on the network this is it
just keeps getting bigger and more and
more demand on the network from packets
to demand the bandwidth the average
student today brings between 6 to 8
devices to school that want to attach to
the network gaming systems iPads phones
iwatches
IOT devices doorbells for the for their
rooms I mean so it just continues to
grow and then grow
applications moving to the cloud I could
personally speak about this because I
ran the cloud technologies group and the
push for size applications
infrastructure as a service AWS as your
Google platforms doing compute out in
the cloud big data storage out in the
cloud this is taxing our network going
out of the university and how do we
handle that higher speeds for for
research moving data across the
university we have a high performance
computing Center at West Campus they
need to move big amounts of data over
there for the 40,000 cores that they
have to process that data and now we're
even talking about regionally how do we
how do we collaborate with UMass and all
these other institutions on the
Northeast I'm a member of the Northeast
Regional Network team that's trying to
build a much faster network throughout
the Northeast there's one in the on the
west coast it's called quilts very
similar but these these are big demands
especially in research bring your own
devices I talked about that just
attaching the Wi-Fi we could have an
average of about 30,000 divided people
on the network in a in a peak day which
is quite big
just for this campus what I'll talk
about too is is the technical debt and a
lot of universities are seeing this you
know the investment
in the network was never really there
over the last ten years however the
network technology has taken leaps and
bounds in the last ten years of the
technology from software-defined
networking to software-defined access to
perimeters that we put in and being able
to machine learn devices that come on
the network and how do how do we deal
with it so I talked a little bit about
the growing dependencies so for Yale
academic delivery right books are mine I
have a son that's going to college next
year now they're actually now selling
pages online pages of a book that you
can buy for a week right on a specific
topic so you know the demand more for
video and stuff like that and academic
delivery is is is getting very a bigger
research I talked about that it's just
very overwhelming for me even just to
figure out how this data gets move we're
actually talking about how do we
actually move the compute to the data
using what we call containerization you
know we build containers here and I'm
going to move those containers to UMass
and let them and process on their data
so the collaboration with the other
universities is big and just even on
campus we have what we call the science
Network and a science network is a
physical network as a hundred gig
network but it's only in specific
buildings that are needed
like there's no science set in this
building but there is one getting ready
for the big science building that's
coming up clinical care as many know I
mean you know the the call centers today
we run call centers on the Yale School
of Medicine side you call them
everything's on the computer they know
who you are they know you know what
appointments you're gonna have what your
test results look like things like that
to help you through and even to the to
the point where these doctors are in in
a Yale health plan where they have carts
and stuff that needs to connect to the
network things like that so you get no
more paper anymore we were just talking
the other day about Milford Hospital
Yale New Haven health services board
milford hospital
well they they were never computerized
as you know to the point where we are
today I mean they have basic computer
ization but a lot of the records were
our manual records which is it's they're
going to be spending quite a bit of
money on getting getting mil for
Hospital up and running and of course
the cultural heritage side for worldwide
scholars the biggest challenge for us in
this area is that digital born
collections are very important and how
do you preserve those where do you
preserve those where you know you you
have to save those in like eight
different places around the the the
country sometimes right so I'm working
actually very closely with the library
on trying to define do we need a
cultural heritage digital digital
collection type of network built into
our architecture and what does that mean
for the museums as well as the libraries
that are tied to it very simple we have
a very aging Network very old mixture of
many many different technologies it's a
complete comprehensive replacement of
the hardware throughout the network and
I'll I'll show you the numbers what that
means the security side of this is built
gonna be built into the network it's a
different type of model on how we
actually intercept different things that
are happening on the network how we can
pickups you know a device that's across
campus and say oh that's playing really
badly I just want to put it over here
I'll put them in a different network
that's kind of safe where today a lot of
times you'll see part of my team running
out of the building try to go find that
in the building right so it's it's it's
very very manual process and we'll talk
about the number of networks so the key
thing really is for for me is the
reliability the resiliency the
visibility of
network I put just felt thousand words
here and this is not the worst one I
just tell you this you know that pipe I
hit my head on it when I went to go see
it so you know we we have state the the
physical state of the network just even
the closets that are around campus are
in really poor shape there may not
managed properly there's there's a lot
of work that needs to be done just in
the conditioning of some of these old
buildings that we have to do and the
project itself you know I'll give you a
little preference on how this project
happened it you know it's it's a
five-year project and I spent probably
eight months working with the budget
advisory groups the financial committees
the business office all the way up to
the Board of Directors the the
presentations for this and we've been
fully approved not committed but fully
approved to spend fifty million dollars
to replace this network so it's it's a
big number
as you know to tell here fifty-five
percent of the equipment is beyond its
recommended service age the
segmentations are concerned to to the
security side of things just and just in
general I mean we probably have about
four different types of manufacturers of
switching equipment and Wi-Fi points so
here are the key deliverables so we need
to remediate about fourteen hundred
rooms closets that connect all the
floors in one building
so this could range from a complete redo
to the room to just wiring to just even
securing the room we have rooms where
they're just in closets we have a room
that's in a to get to it you have to go
through the women's restroom you know so
it's it's very difficult to even keep
control of these rooms just from a
physical standpoint some of them don't
have key locks on it or proxy locks on
it we find peep
put things in it like a microwave in the
room or something like that so so we
have to take better control of these
rooms and you know everything from even
air conditioning and power and fiber
connections to specific rooms so it is a
very lengthy process here a very
assessment a long assessment that has to
go on with this but it's going to go on
for the next five years just assessing
and remediating the rooms we're
replacing about 9,000 devices that
includes Wi-Fi devices as well the Wi-Fi
devices we have actually a big
investment in new a white Wi-Fi devices
so we'll let them age out and replace
them as they get replaced over time
consolidating five networks and we've
focused on five networks only because
those are the five biggest networks we
have many other physical networks and
these are physical so if you go into a
closet you will see a rack of switches
three times let's say one for facilities
of facilities network one for a public
safety network one for campus network
that's going to come together through
software-defined networking right into
one one architecture role base access
the you'll see in the back part as we go
through the presentation that role based
access is defining who you are and what
you what you get on the network there's
researchers who are going to need a
hundred a hundred gig connection so we
can define that for a researcher where
you can have the administrative office
that just needs to access and maybe
needs like you know a five gig
connection versus a 10 100 gig
connection who you are where you are is
going to define your different roles if
I'm a clinician I want to be able to
move from here to Yale New Haven Health
and be able to use my same idea and not
have multiply these that's that's the
the role based access piece of it and
automating cyber security sponsors I
spoke a little bit about it but it's
more machine based response in
is manual responsive so so talk a little
bit about these in the last night but
seamless user experience no matter what
profile you're in if you're just a
student where you deal with low-risk
data or if you're a clinician who deals
with HIPAA or a researcher that deals
with different other fer / or Eph I data
though you know it's it's going to be
seamless you go here you go to a
different network you know over the med
campus which is a different network and
you'll have that seamless connection to
all your resources even if your VPN and
they'll be the same thing you'll just be
looking like a remote site on on to the
network faster speeds are going to go 10
to 40 times faster I mean really the
network it's not it's not the fibre it's
not the cabling and that word gets to
switching right so we change these
switches to a much more robust faster
switching technology fewer network
disruptions I'm I I've been in this
position now for a little bit over a
year I made it very visible on weekly
updates about outages that are happening
around campus - oh wait - the Provost
it's like this you know this week we had
eight outages three buildings down you
know and it was important to do that
because we never did that before and
making that given that visibility's
really shows the concern that we've had
machine speed detection for breaches
again built into the network there's
there's this this is security define
access and they call ice which is
another another piece of it that on DNA
Center which is another piece of it that
is going to you know help with the
Machine detection invisibility of where
things are happening it's it like I said
it's very very difficult today to
actually find those fine things here's a
very high level
schedule we spent a good part of FY 19
really from a programmatic perspective
building a team we are moving to all
Cisco technology I have got a lot of
questions about that we actually have
Cisco here on site for the next two
years their advanced services and
engineering teams are here working with
the teams we have a number of different
providers that work with Cisco that are
here to help us with deployment and
architecture so we spent this year
really programmatically bringing the
team together understanding what it
means and working on the design and
architecture piece of this program we're
starting with some pilot buildings
probably I think very soon this summer
25 Science Park is going to be the first
one because we're gonna eat our own dog
food and learn from that but we're
taking two administrative buildings on
central campus here and then there's
been a little bit of a turn of the tides
because of some recent things that have
happened with the meds med school campus
network but we are accelerating a
deployment on the med school site to
correct some some major issues there so
over the next once we get through the
pilot site cycle I think once we get
through FY 20 will have a whole
deployment plan ready to go for the next
few years and it's just really going
through each of those buildings up front
of this there's a couple other work
streams like I mentioned we're looking
at the whole fiber plant on the
university making sure we have diverse
connections and
you're going out
I'll speak louder
looks like it went out so we're looking
at the rooms and stuff so we're trying
to get that what we call layer one set
in place before we start putting in the
electronics okay
so we're defining this in two different
releases the foundational release which
I mentioned before is is focused on
resiliency reliability stability
visibility and and and hopefully when we
do that phase my emails each week to the
Provost's on the down down buildings
will reduce down to nothing because
that's really the the primary focus of
this and then moving into the advanced
security side of things we have a lab
set up now at Science Park and you know
we're gonna have teams of people Public
Safety coming in trying all their
devices
you know facilities has an enormous
amount of devices just to run a building
they need to test all those in the lab
before we roll out and config those
they're when you plug something into the
network if it is not defined through a
configuration it will not be allowed on
network it will be put in a space that
has to have a config made for it type
okay all right so we're hoping that over
time that that will that will be easy
easily done to allow those devices but
we do get we do get devices plugged into
the network that spew a lot of different
traffic that that hurts our network
today so where are we I spoke a little
bit about this designs are 80% complete
our teams are still building but the
core team is has been working the last
year on the implementation side of
things as well as the pilot for the
pilot buildings and then looking ahead
for what the next couple years look like
what's next is again the detail
migrations plans we're gonna focus out
on West Campus in the beginning probably
as the normal project begins only
because we have a little more
flexibility with the the layer one piece
of West Campus so from a physical plant
standpoint use cases we need to build
use cases that's our one of our next
steps as well meeting with the research
community meeting with the clinical
community meeting with the facilities
community and understand all the use
cases that need to happen for for for
that in those areas and also the
academic side that's all I have
Wow I'll be around for a while should
any other questions thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]